this episode of the good doctor is a
made-up story about a real battle still
being fought
honor the heroes doctors nurses and
other frontline workers
many of whom who have given their lives
do your part wear a mask
great message
i love the way they're showing the viral
particles they're just spreading out
everywhere that absolutely
does happen that's why it's really
important to dab when you cough to try
and limit that spread
we've seen it actually spray six feet
away from you when you cough
or sneeze and germs have hang time so
you can walk into an empty room that
someone just sneezed in and be exposed
to those germs
i don't know why i did that
and there you go this is such a good
example of how germs spread
droplets meaning someone coughs or
sneezes or speaks
contact meaning they cough on their
hands and they touch something they give
it to somebody else when we talk about
disinfecting your hands
wearing a mask we're talking about
decreasing droplet spread and contact
spread have you seen my id badge
no i had it last night but maybe it
fell out of my back i lose my id badge
all the time
like not permanently lose it but have it
in my car in my trunk in my suitcase
in my home sometimes bear steals it
sorry bear your temperature's almost
101.
your other symptoms first it was a sore
throat
then my body started aching
and then there's this cough i even had
my flu shot
unfortunately influenza is constantly
mutating the
shot always lags behind both very
accurate statements in fact during this
time frame in february
i was working in my primary care office
we knew covid was around but we didn't
think it it was everywhere yet
so a lot of patients were coming to my
practice with upper respiratory viral
symptoms just like this
fever cough muscle aches and we thought
they potentially had influenza
we gave them antivirals for influenza
the reality is even if you had your flu
shot you can still get the flu but
your case should be milder my daughter
is very worried that i might have this
virus from china what's it called have
you been to china or been around anyone
who's been to china recently those are
the questions we were asking
at that time i think we were referring
it to encove 19 right was it nco of 19.
the virus has damaged your mother's
lungs
her body is working harder and harder to
breathe but her blood oxygen levels
continue to drop
she definitely has corona
we're doing everything we can to help
her
see that patient was actually in a
negative pressure air room they were
isolated from other
people because at that point we were
deciding whether covet 19 was only
needed to maintain a droplet precaution
where you just cover your face in the
patient's
face with a mask or do we need negative
pressure room because covid was spread
through
airborne transmission where the virus
just lived in aerosolized particles
in the air all the time and what we came
to realize is it's more of a droplet
spread
but there are some instances where it
can be spread through aerosolized
particles
especially during medical procedures
like intubations
you have covered
okay now what now you go home
that's it that's it there's no treatment
stay away from people come back if you
have trouble breathing goodbye
i forget because i don't watch this show
regularly how funny shawn is covet 19 is
a viral illness
so if your oxygen levels are not
dropping drastically
and you just kind of feel lousy and you
have a mild fever your body is the one
that has to
fight this off like there's very little
that we can actually do in the hospital
systems
and by keeping you in the hospital we're
actually increasing the risk
to healthcare providers and other
patients 25 tests
per day no just give me one of
tomorrow's
hello county health department i don't
have time for them and apparently they
don't have time for me
i remember in march i had a patient who
i suspected to have covet 19 but i
didn't have a test available so i was
calling the department of health trying
to secure a test for them eventually
getting them a test
finding out that they were in fact
positive luckily everyone was wearing a
mask at that point
so we decreased the spread we cleaned
the room sent them out the back door
tried to do our best to limit the spread
of this virus there's just a lot of
things we didn't know in the beginning
that we know now
if i'm sick is my baby sick this disease
doesn't really seem to affect children
or babies like it does adults
should we admit her she's probably safer
at home
once at home do you have a support
system can anyone come help you
should get worse it's just me
and the little one good doctors always
ask questions like this if i'm sending a
patient home that i'm sort of
questionable on
and let's say they had a concussion i
always want to make sure there's someone
to keep an eye on them that if they
become unconscious they have someone to
call for help and to check on them if i
come home do you want me living with you
of course that's the point every night
after 12 hours of covet patience to hang
out with you
and kellen and his asthma interestingly
enough we've seen conflicting reports on
how covid19 affects those with asthma
now if it's just
asthma alone it doesn't seem to be as
bad as we expected it to be
but those who are asthmatic and have
other comorbidities like heart disease
obesity
those are the patients that seem to be
experiencing worse symptoms
and worse outcomes we do everything we
can we hammer
at official channels in every
manufacturer's rep
that we deal with and see what companies
if any have under nuts or no nuts
uh oh i'm sorry i'm i'm in the middle of
a meeting with abort hey everyone
i'm just making banana bread one of the
most searched
terms in the height of this pandemic was
how to make sourdough bread
go figure i've never made sourdough
bread i've never googled it i don't know
who's sitting at home googling it but
apparently
sourdough bread was the thing everyone
was making not banana bread
your husband's blood oxygen level is
dangerously low
that can't there can't be so one of the
hallmark symptoms of cova 19 is decrease
oxygen saturation in your blood where
you're actually not getting enough
oxygen
from usually the edema or the scarring
that's happening
in your lungs as a result of the
inflammation that occurs with this virus
one of the
dangerous parts of covid19 is not only
are you infected with this virus that
you're fighting off
but some people have an overreaction or
a cytokine storm where all these
inflammatory cells come to the lungs
and actually cause a bigger problem
where you can't get enough oxygen going
and being delivered to the rest of your
body
your vital organs your liver your
kidneys your brain and so forth our
solution to that was to
ventilate meaning intubate all these
patients and as we did that more and
more often without treating them with
proper medications like we have now and
we know which ones work
patients actually got worse on
ventilators because we were over
ventilating people
and it's not because we're stupid or we
were intentionally harming people
but it was simply because it's a novel
virus and we did not have guidelines on
how to best
treat patients with it we were learning
about it on the go we have a surplus of
ekg leads
no we've got a shortage but that's a
problem that can wait the pve situation
was really dire
in the beginning of this pandemic
because china was hit first and a lot of
our manufacturing facilities
are in china and because of that they
actually redirected all of their
shipments to their country because they
needed them and as a result we were
facing a lot of shortages
for gloves for ekg leads for swabs for
test kits antibacterial wipes the vials
for injections
the wiring and the tubing for
ventilators
there were so many shortages that were
happening simultaneously it was a truly
dire situation especially here
in the new york city area
him rubbing his ears like that is from
the mask oh my god in the beginning just
wearing the mask for
countless hours my ears hurt so much i
just remember
being so sore but as we learned to use
those little head pieces in the back
where you could actually
have the mask stay on there as opposed
to on your ears it made the world of a
difference
and for those of you who haven't ever
worn an n95 mask they're uncomfortable
because they offer more protection
they're more form-fitting you have to
get them fit tested but they also put a
lot of pressure on your face they leave
marks that's why all those pictures were
making the rounds of nurses doctors
who were having bruising in that area
from just wearing them day in and day
out
and a lot of times they were reusing
equipment that was meant to be
disposable
you work in a hospital yes could you
wait
for the next elevator
i appreciate you
you know it's funny um in new york if
you ever wore your scrubs out during
that period
everyone wanted to say thank you and was
quite grateful and that's
amazing but at the same time everyone
wanted to keep their distance
rightfully so i understand you don't
want to put yourself or your family
members at risk but it didn't feel good
that you were being alienated like that
so it's part of the process my mother is
in there all alone hooked up to a
machine i just need to see her
and tell her that i love her there's a
human toll
that it takes on family members not
being able to see your family member and
if you're the one ill not seeing your
family members i will also
venture to say and i don't have evidence
for this but i will say that
hospital errors do go up if you do not
have family members
present in advocating on your behalf
especially if you're unconscious
now what we've learned from that is
we're trying to keep families more
updated trying to keep them involved
if they're not there at the bedside
through virtual care giving them
scheduled
regular phone calls because we realize
that when we're in better communication
with the family
we actually get better outcomes for our
patients
pushing effie
why is no one doing chest compressions i
don't understand do some tricks
compression
it's clear do some chest compressions
lift up now
did you see those horrible chess cameras
she just put her hands on the chest
didn't even compress 200
clear okay i don't know
what these people have high-end experts
on set
you start chest compressions and then
you use a defibrillation you know i have
heard in the beginning of the pandemic
because i wasn't
in the hospitals i was seeing patients
outpatient that they were decreasing the
amount of chest compressions being done
because they were worried about
aerosolizing the virus i actually just
looked this up from the red cross
performing chess compressions
while wearing proper medical protective
equipment and 95 respirators or like
how they have the whole body suit on
still means you should do chest
compressions like do them do them do
them i don't know why they weren't doing
them i was trying to make excuses for
them they should have been doing chest
compressions from the start
any cough any fever
no any shortness of breath sore throat
loss of smell
no no none of that just searing
abdominal pain
and the runs i'm pretty sure it's my
diverticulitis acting up
my roommate is deeply into pandemic
baking
i've avoided coming in i don't want to
catch covet so one of the biggest
problems we faced
during this pandemic was patients not
coming into the hospitals
and in the beginning when we were really
overwhelmed that made a lot of sense
but as we became safer for patients to
come in we had
different policies in place in order to
decrease spread our testing improved our
capacity improved our ppe improved
we wanted patients to come back because
a lot of times when patients delay care
their diseases and conditions get more
advanced
and as a result become more difficult to
treat patients who were having
uh some signs of heart attacks were
coming in much later
and as a result some of our mainstays
treatments weren't working as well and
the recoveries took longer one of my
main messages over the last two three
months
has been to encourage patients to call
their primary care offices to call
hospitals
to come in for the symptoms that are
bothering them and not wait it's pink
active i'm breathing great
[Music]
in the midst of our research with covet
19 we actually found that there was
limited spread
from mother to fetus of covet 19 meaning
that the mother
could be testing positive cover 19 the
baby was usually safe now it doesn't
mean there was no spread there were some
case reports of it happening
but for the large majority we did not
want mothers to panic because it wasn't
happening
and children in general seem to fare
better with this virus anyway
the numbers of children below the age of
10 dying with cover 19
were spectacularly low that doesn't mean
it's completely benign for them because
they could also spread this virus and be
vectors but it is reassuring
for mothers especially with the levels
of anxiety that they are facing for
[Music]
themselves
please don't put your masks on the floor
and then put them back on your face
sean you're a doctor buddy don't put it
on the floor
i talked about germs having hang time
about the
hanging out in the air but folks after
they hang out in the air for those
minutes or hours where they go right on
the floor
especially if you're walking around a
hospital setting and then you come home
with your shoes on guess what's on that
mask
man couldn't they just have me on set
for one of these things
could have helped make it so much more
accurate
my hospital actually created a
state-of-the-art coven 19 ward
check it out as i give you the tour for
that in a day my life video
or check out all of my good doctor
reviews here in a playlist
i made just for you and as always stay
happy and healthy
and stay alert not anxious